does a director automatically deserve
respect
no um
I mean you know I think that the
director automatically wants respect
but they don't necessarily deserve it I
think
and when you see frustration from
directors it's because they don't have
any respect and people are just walking
all over him that usually comes from a
director that is
not prepared or not
prepared and just not doing the job that
they're supposed to be doing
um
it they sh they need respect they should
have respect because you're in charge of
uh some usually something larger even if
it's a smaller production you know you
still got some money on the line
um
but they you got you're you're the
person in the position of
a pile of money
you have a Target that you're aiming for
at the end of it with some sort of
story or something
um
you have to dictate things to all these
other departments and if they don't have
your respect they are not going to be
delivering their best work more than
likely because if they don't like you if
they're if they don't
respect you or don't want to be there
they're going to probably just try to
they're just trying to power through the
day that's a really bad that you don't
want your team members in that position
um and I don't think that that if you
find yourself in that position it's this
is not necessarily because you have
experience or not that's not usually
doesn't have anything to do with it it's
usually has to do with
your preparation uh
directors who are not prepared
really lose the respect of their crew
very quickly because the worst possible
thing you can do on set as a director is
not know what you want to sit there
the clock is ticking and you're going
should we put the we should put the
camera so if we put the camera
here
and then
ah it makes everyone crazy and they're
going to start rolling their eyes and
being very frustrated with you and
they're going to start a second guessing
your decisions and things like that
coming into your location beforehand and
knowing they're going to enter through
this door and they're going to go out to
that door and I I want to just move the
camera this way you don't have to know
every little detail but having an idea
of what you want
um it's super important and you could do
that without experience
and if you don't know how to to even
shoot a scene you can get your DP to
help you with that as long as you know
what you want that becomes from
preparation
um
even having like an idea of say for
example a wardrobe you know you want I
want it to look like this guy has been
up all night
that can be enough of a description for
your wardrobe person at least now they
know what you want okay so he's he slept
in his clothes okay good
and so a little bit of wrinkles in yeah
yeah you know that kind of thing if you
came in and you're like
I don't know he's just wearing like
clothes like normal
that's maddening to work for You're
Gonna Lose the respect of everybody
really quickly so it's absolutely vital
to have respect but it's not something
that you will get just automatically
um
but you can get it by making sure you're
doing the work so shot listing and
storyboarding yep shot listing
storyboarding is very helpful uh you
don't have to storyboard necessarily
there's a lot of schools of thought on
that it depends on the style that you're
going for sometimes uh
you don't have time you know so like
there's a show I've been working on
where we're running so fast there's not
time for storyboards there's not even
time for a shot list but at least
um knowing the basics even like I'm
prepared as much as I can be in the
moment I know that these two characters
are coming in and this is their
objective and we have to get them back
out and we have to do it in five minutes
or less so at least having some goal
posts to hit at a minimum is helpful the
more you know the better it is and the
easier it is for your team to work with
you
what's your image of a Bad director
Badger you know I've seen a lot of bad
directors I can picture them in my mind
that you know the first believe it or
not the first sign I see of a Bad
director is someone who doesn't know how
to talk to an actor
I I think think about
what it takes to be a director
you can do it
the best place for a director to be is
like television you can go into a
television and uh the DP already is set
to look
the this
the writers wrote everything for you
the actors know their characters and uh
you don't really have to do anything but
the the the DP is probably going to be
able to set it up and while we normally
shoot it when the guy goes over here and
he cooks dinner there this is normally
how we shoot the scene okay great the
actors are still going to know what you
want
so if you don't know how to talk to them
and they're and they're feeling alone
and vulnerable that that's that's a
problem
um
and that is the one job
that no one can really help you with
someone else can light it someone else
can get all the costumes ready in the
stunts and stuff but
someone's got to talk to the actors
someone's going to give them emotions
and and help
pull moments out of them especially if
they've shut down who else is going to
do that for you you it's up to you so
um
there's no more important job than that
I think
how do you gut check yourself
to know hey am I moving into Bad
director mode
yeah you know
if I feel like
I'm in danger of being a bad director
I'm just I'm waiting for all the commas
to appear below the video like you are a
bad director
if I feel like I'm I'm edging into that
territory it always comes down to my
prep
if I find myself
department heads are asking me
so um what do you want for the color of
the walls and I haven't thought about
that yet
um
I know that
especially if we're approaching the
shoot I know that there's a problem and
especially if there are gaps like
what I've noticed is is what I was
called bad directing
it's really easy to focus just on one
aspect of the shoot like
oh it's going to be in this
place all lit with Christmas lights and
and it's going to be shot on a Steadicam
and we're going to spin in a circle cool
so what are the actors doing oh we'll
figure that out when we get there uh you
haven't really thought about that
department too much
um
that's uh that's that's usually my gut
going alarm Bells alarm Bells you know
you you need to take a minute and sit
and think about that this comes back to
a big thing I think we all struggle with
which is resistance
uh your gut you inside know what you
need to do to be successful but
sometimes for whatever reason Boop it
comes up where you you just don't want
to
um you'll resist sitting down and
writing out your shot list because it
feels a lot like work
so I know that if I if there are there's
usually that thing and sometimes it's
shotless and I like doing shot lists
that's what's so crazy but if I feel
like I haven't done it or see that I
haven't done it and my alarm bells are
going off inside I'm definitely leaning
into bad territory and I feel it on set
because there's always this little sense
of inner Panic that comes up where
um
I don't know what I'm what I'm doing
here
it's it is a really uncomfortable bad
spot to be in when it happens uh because
it's already hard enough on set it's
already
and you know where else it comes up is
where I think that I don't need to think
about it
whenever I approach a situation where uh
it's just another breakup scene
we shot a bunch of these it's just gonna
be in the ice cream shop the two thing
they're going to leave
and I don't put the work in because I
don't feel like I really need to that's
usually when things really go south too
oh the ice cream shop is closed and they
and the actor is allergic to Dairy
oh
um oh well I don't know what to do you
know that because that kind of thing
will happen it just happens all the time
so
which is why you prepare which is why
you do the work ahead of time you're
preparing for Murphy because Murphy will
show up he will
make no mistake about it that's why you
prepare because everything's going to go
sideways on you at some point it just
will so
you've brought up resistance a lot are
you a fan of the war of Art
yes the war yes because that's how it
starts right he talks about resistance
that that really rung my bell when he
talked about that like because you the
thing about resistance that's so
Sinister is that no one else can tell
you we can we're really good at making
ourselves look busy
even to our partners or on social media
but we know if we're resisting we're the
only ones who know generally you know if
you're supposed if you know that you
have that screenplay that you're
supposed to be writing and you just
aren't
no one's your partner may be looking
you'd be oh he works on it every day but
is he though am I though
you know we We Only We Know It And so
it's uh yeah it
and it can look like all sorts of things
it can look like
it can look like uh
exercise
uh every time I sit down and write that
oh I just need to go for a walk oh guess
what you're not doing while you're
walking you're not riding it could look
like
I think he even says in the book it
could be sex could be a resistance thing
you know you just
suddenly I'm really horny
um
yeah for every person is different
social media is probably the biggest
resistance uh blocker which is you know
and social media is a killer for art
it's killer it doesn't you know favors
whatsoever it's
there really isn't any purpose to it
especially for artists like what are you
doing if like what do we really need it
for
you know how is it actually helping your
career we like to we like to kid
ourselves and tell us that oh well
people need to know that I'm busy
do they though like how many jobs have
we legitimately gotten from Facebook
I mean unless you're in part of a
Facebook group that you
post a job and you happen to be one of
the first five that do it and they're
looking for an art Department person
I I can't think of it I people will
message me and say it looks like you're
busy but I've never landed a job from
one of those social media platforms it's
all about the grand advertisement to
show people that
you're more important than you are
that's usually the point of social media
is
yeah
it's not the point of everything
to advertise to the world that you're
more successful more good looking more
that your life is so great and perfect
probably isn't that what we do as humans
yeah we just want to fool everyone into
thinking that we're something